Nach diesem Video weißt Du, was Kobe
Bryants „Mamba-Mentalität“ genau ist,
auf welchen 5 Säulen diese basiert und wie wir
diese auf unser eigenes Leben anwenden können.
„Das Wichtigste ist es Menschen zu inspirieren,
damit sie Großes erreichen können.“
Kobe Bryant
war ein US-amerikanischer Basketballspieler,
verbrachte seine gesamte 20-jährige Karriere
bei den Los Angeles Lakers in der NBA und gewann
fünf NBA-Meisterschaften. Er gilt als einer der
größten Basketballspieler aller Zeiten.
Kobe
gab sich selbst den Spitznamen "Black Mamba",
eine der gefährlichsten Schlangen Afrikas,
wegen ihrer Größe, Schnelligkeit und ihres
extrem starken Giftes.
"The Black Mamba" wurde
auf der ganzen Welt nicht nur für sein Spiel
auf dem Platz geliebt, sondern auch für seine
Einstellung und Mentalität.
Kobe hatte eine
ganz bestimmte Einstellung zum Leben, die
er als "Mamba-Mentalität" bezeichnete.
Kobe sagte:
"Mamba-Mentalität bedeutet einfach,
zu versuchen, die beste Version von sich selbst
zu sein. Jeden Tag, der Versuch, besser zu
werden."
Wie können wir für uns und unser
Leben Kobes Mamba Mentalität nutzen, um die
beste Version unserer selbst zu werden?
Nun,
die Mamba Mentalität lässt sich auf fünf
Säulen herunterbrechen. Lasst uns herausfinden,
welche diese sind und wie wir diese auf unser
eigenes Leben anwenden können.
1. Leidenschaft
Leidenschaftlich zu sein bedeutet, das zu
lieben, was man tut. Kobe z.B. liebte nicht nur
Basketball zu spielen, sondern auch den Geruch
von Basketball, den Geruch von neuen Sneakers,
das Geräusch von der Reibung zwischen Basketball,
Turnschuhen und dem Spielfeld. Er liebte im Grunde
alles rund um den Basketball.
Aber wie können
wir unsere Leidenschaft finden?
Kobe rät hierzu,
sich einfach so vielen verschiedenen
Dingen auszusetzen und auszuprobieren,
wie man kann. Dabei werden wir etwas finden, zu
das wir uns am meisten hingezogen fühlen. Das
ist dann die Sache, für die wir uns am meisten
begeistern.
Leidenschaft gehört zu den Dingen,
die man nicht fälschen oder aus dem Nichts
erschaffen kann. Ob im Sport, in der Kunst oder
im Unternehmertum - die Leidenschaft steht bei der
Mamba-Mentalität im Vordergrund.
Leidenschaftlich
zu sein ist absolut notwendig, um das Beste
aus sich herauszuholen.
2. Besessenheit
Besessen zu sein bedeutet, so viel Mühe und
Zeit wie möglich in unsere Leidenschaft zu
stecken.
Wenn wir etwas Außergewöhnliches
erreichen wollen, müssen wir uns außerordentlich
anstrengen und enorme Zeit dafür aufwenden.
Kobe stand morgens um 3 Uhr auf, damit er um 4
Uhr mit seinem Training beginnen konnte. Er
machte das schon seit der Highschool.
Für
ihn war es gesunder Menschenverstand, dass man für
das, was einem wichtig ist, hart arbeiten muss.
Er schöpfte ebenso viel Selbstvertrauen aus der
Vorbereitung. Mit all dem intensiven Training
war er für jedes Spiel sehr gut vorbereitet.
Er
sagte:
"Ich habe nichts übrig für faule Menschen,
die anderen die Schuld für ihren mangelnden
Erfolg geben. Große Dinge entstehen durch harte
Arbeit und Beharrlichkeit. Keine Ausreden."
Jedes
einzelne Dribbling, jeder Pump Fake, jeder Pass,
jeder Wurf, jede Defensivaufgabe wurde von Kobe
ununterbrochen geübt.
Er fertigte sich sogar
Entwürfe für bestimmte Situationen im Spiel
an, die mit verschiedenen Lösungsmöglichkeiten
gekennzeichnet waren, so dass er auf
alle Eventualitäten reagieren konnte.
Weiterhin verbrachte er unzählige Stunden
in der Videoanalyse von Gegnern.
Diese
enorme Vorbereitung war der Schlüssel zu seiner
Größe.
Er sagte hierzu:
"Viele Menschen sagen,
dass sie großartig sein wollen, aber sie sind
nicht bereit, die notwendigen Opfer zu bringen,
um Größe zu erreichen.“
3. Unnachgiebigkeit
Wie wir gesehen haben, war Kobe sehr streng mit
sich selbst, was man schon allein daran sehen
kann, dass er jeden Tag um 4 Uhr morgens mit dem
Training begann.
Nach seiner Logik erlaubte
ihm ein früherer Start, mehr zu schaffen
als seine NBA-Kollegen - manchmal mehrere
Stunden Training mehr pro Tag.
Er glaubte,
dass ihn das im Laufe seiner Karriere so weit
von den anderen trennen würde, dass sie nie den
Rückstand aufholen könnten.
Für die meisten
Menschen, liegt der Grund, warum diese nichts
Außergewöhnliches erreichen können, darin, dass
sie immer gewöhnliche Dinge tun. Also kann das
Ergebnis, zu dem es führt, nur gewöhnlich sein.
"Sei unnachgiebig.", sagte Kobe.
Unnachgiebig,
durch Alter und Verletzungen hindurch, setzte
Kobe kaum Spiele aus. Er verließ die NBA erst,
als sein Körper ihn zum Aufhören zwang. Er
hat alles auf dem Spielfeld gelassen. Er hat
sich allen Herausforderungen gestellt. Er gab
seinen Teamkameraden, Trainern und Fans alles,
was er hatte. Das ist Unnachgiebigkeit.
4.
Widerstandsfähigkeit
In den ersten knapp 15
Jahren seiner Karriere hatte Kobe keine größeren
Verletzungen. Er spielte die überwiegende Mehrheit
der Spiele seiner Mannschaft in der regulären
Saison und den Playoffs. Während dieser Zeit
spielte er jedoch durch viele kleinere, nervende,
wiederkehrende Verletzungen. Gebrochene Finger,
kaputte Knöchel, verstauchte Schultern, Knie,
Handgelenke usw. Er gewann Meisterschaften,
während Verletzungen ihn plagten.
Erst in
der Saison 2013-2014 verpasste Kobe aufgrund
einer schweren Verletzung der Achillessehne viel
Zeit.
Als die schlimmste Art von Verletzung,
die ein Sportler erleiden kann, und im Alter von
35 Jahren, stellte sich Kobe dieser Verletzung
und der Reha Maßnahmen, um wieder auf das
Spielfeld zurückzukehren.
Und das tat er.
Zwei weitere Spielzeiten lang spielte Kobe
in der NBA, und er tat es effektiv, obwohl
ihn schließlich das Alter und die Verletzungen
so sehr zermürbten, dass er seinen Rücktritt
akzeptierte.
Die Widerstandsfähigkeit auf dem
Spielfeld machte seine 20-jährige Karriere zu
einer der glanzvollsten aller Spieler, die
jemals auf dem Platz standen.
Die eigene
Leidenschaft aufzugeben war keine Option für Kobe.
Es ist manchmal entmutigend, immer zu versuchen,
das langfristige Ziel im Auge zu behalten. Wenn
Rückschläge passieren, und das werden sie, sollten
wir einen Fuß vor den anderen setzen. Wir sollten
die Dinge in Abschnitte bzw. kleine kurzfristige
Ziele unterteilen und uns Schritt für Schritt
vorarbeiten.
Kobe's Widerstandsfähigkeit brachte
ihm die Möglichkeit, kontinuierlich an seinen
Fähigkeiten zu arbeiten, Saison für Saison besser
zu werden und schließlich als Legende bezeichnet
zu werden.
Er sagte hierzu:
„Alles Negative -
Druck, Herausforderungen - sind nur Möglichkeiten
um besser zu werden.“
5. Furchtlosigkeit
Dies
ist die letzte Komponente der Mamba-Mentalität.
Laut Kobe bedeutet Furchtlosigkeit, sich in seine
Ängste hineinzuversetzen, anstatt vor ihnen
wegzulaufen. Diese Philosophie ruft dazu auf,
die Angst zu umarmen, denn die Anwesenheit von
Angst verspricht eine Art von Wachstum auf der
anderen Seite von ihr.
Kobe sagte hierzu:
"Die
größte Angst, die wir haben, sind wir selbst. Wir
alle haben Träume, und es ist manchmal sehr
beängstigend, den Traum zu akzeptieren, den
man hat. Und noch beängstigender ist es, zu sagen:
'Ich will diesen Traum.' Es ist beängstigend. Weil
man Angst hat, wenn man sein Herz und seine Seele
hineinsteckt und scheitert, wie wird man sich
dann selbst fühlen? Furchtlos zu sein bedeutet
also, dass man sich traut und es durchzieht,
egal was passiert. Ziehe es durch. Nicht für
jemand anderen, sondern für dich selbst."
Das waren die 5 Säulen der Mamba Mentalität.
Leidenschaft, Besessenheit, Unnachgiebigkeit,
Widerstandsfähigkeit und Furchtlosigkeit.
Kobe sagte zur Mamba-Mentalität:
"Bei diesem
Mindset geht es nicht darum, ein Ergebnis
anzustreben - es geht mehr um den Prozess,
um zu diesem Ergebnis zu gelangen. Es geht um die
Reise und den Ansatz. Es ist eine Art zu leben.
Ich denke, dass es bei allen Unternehmungen
wichtig ist, diese Mentalität zu haben."
Der
Tod von Kobe war ein großer Verlust nicht nur
für seine Familie, sondern auch für die Welt,
da er ein Mensch war, der viele andere Menschen,
nicht nur mit seinen sportlichen Leistungen,
sondern auch mit seiner Einstellung und Mentalität
inspiriert hat. Seine Mamba-Mentalität wird uns
weiterhin erhalten bleiben und viele weitere
Menschen positiv beeinflussen. Danke Kobe.